somebody works out
the shadow wants a story is about Clary
Fray being sucked into the Shadowhunters
world with the tagline is all the
legends are true so everything you ever
grew up hearing about and the fairy
tales they all exist in this world hey
watch where you're going you can see me
suddenly on the night of her 18th
birthday things start to happen and she
starts singing all these weird things
and having these weird flashes and
memories and she discovers that she is
in fact a Shadowhunter which is a half
angel half human hybrid we're
Shadowhunters we protect the human world
from the demon world literally my brain
is about to explode
I think people identify with all of
these characters because it's the end of
the day it's not really about the things
that make these characters supernatural
it's about the things that make these
characters human go be a badass shadow
hunter right I'll be right here guarding
the entrance to help their sole purpose
in the world is to protect the humans or
the mundanes from the rest of the shadow
world which consists of demons vampires
werewolves see leaves warlocks in any
other manner of creature what the hell
is happening only if you need it
trust your instincts you weren't
powerful than you know it's such a
diverse group of characters I think that
the the book series you know in itself
is a great series and I think what we've
done here is we've been able to you know
put it into a live-action with the with
the drama and the humor that that made
the book so popular I hold up I've seen
every horror movie ever made and a funny
best friend who gets left behind dead
man you're not that funny
new fans are going to appreciate the
story for
the the drama of it the the fun of it I
mean there's nothing about this that
isn't appealing to a wide audience
you got you got sexy people you got
scary people
you got sexy things that happen you got
scary things happen you got drama action
it's it's very fun I guess yeah I'm
excited honestly to look at all the
relationships the highs and lows and
also of the action and see a show like
this to have a high caliber of action in
it that it is just all
it's all very magical do this yeah you
can your query freaking afraid you can
do anything